[Music]
hey you guys
it's sunday yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
well look
she's gonna [ __ ] with me well we didn't
well you know it's just funny how you're
just not real enthusiastic
i got to be really enthusiastic well
yeah is that what it is come on okay
let's have a good time it's sunday yeah
[ __ ] sunday
we didn't even go we didn't even go out
last night well so you know it's like
you know been spending so much money the
past couple months that's what i'm
saying because we've been going out a
lot i'm just like giving around i just
need to rest honestly yeah that's super
chat money drying up i'm kidding
everybody's [ __ ] everybody's [ __ ]
out of work man
well it's like well and also i'm getting
old and it's like kind of hard like the
last couple weeks we would do the show
you know for three or four hours and
then we'd go out afterward and i was
just like that took me like two or three
days to recover from that yeah so it's
just i think last night i put on we
watched this movie and then we watched
like then i put on like mystery science
theater and i think i fell asleep before
the first i think i fell asleep at like
9 30 or some [ __ ]
i just invented a new drink oh
this is um it's half
ginger tea
and half apple juice that [ __ ] is so
good man
tastes like fall
that's good a little bit and i just did
that off the top of my head because [ __ ]
man i can't even wait it's almost
september i know it's still gonna be hot
here in the fall but i can pretend at
least and then there'll be like
halloween [ __ ] in the stores and that'll
be exciting i still haven't found the
key to the lightning i [ __ ] turned
this place upside down look that this
was either a pookie or a poltergeist
[Laughter]
and i can't understand where
would a cat put a dab motorcycle key
well she hit it good if she did hide it
i don't i can't figure out where else it
could be though
if you guys don't know it's got a little
rubber handle on it and she likes to
chew on things that are rubber and she
gets up on the nightstand and i think
that's where i put it i think she went
up there and got it either the poultry
guys got it
yeah which means it could be inside the
walls or something somewhere well maybe
you should ask the poultry guys to get
to give it back to you
it was weird because i was i would
a couple days before
i went for that ride when i last rode
that lightning ride in the lightning
lightning xp9
but before before i rode the lightning i
was thinking i should get an extra key
in case i ever lose one of these and
then look see yeah so you did it maybe
your poltergeist did it maybe but i
found if i have as long as i have the uh
the vin number on the title
and my id to prove that it's me that has
a title
harley davidson can uh make me a copy
key for about 35 bucks takes about a
week it's a lot cheaper than my car yeah
he was so i may have to do that but man
i'm [ __ ] pissed over this [ __ ] yeah
he's torn this whole house up looking
for that anyway um
oh louis
what's that louis said jenny i have an
idea for a future show the flat tire
murders yeah i actually have that on the
list because i think that took place in
uh in florida somewhere like deland or
daytona where i grew up so uh yeah so
that's definitely on the list but yeah
so we watched this one last night
because a couple people had uh
recommended it i had been hearing a lot
about this movie because i guess
it played a lot of um festivals and then
it might have had like a
brief like or a limited theatrical
release and then finally shutter got
hold of it and i've been wanting to see
this one because like you know you you
know how much we love barbara crampton
on the show i mean barbara looks great
in this movie she is she's got to be
what 65 i don't know how old she is she
she's looking just fantastic she she had
some facial work i mean she is just cute
she doesn't quite look like the same
person but she looks fantastic i i'd
like to know what kind of hormones she's
on i got some kind of hormone therapy
yeah because she's right she's pretty
hot in this yeah
she's still very attractive
she even pops at one titties out
yeah you do get to see it i've forgotten
about that yeah you do you get do you
get to see this is a good movie i liked
it um it i think it had it had strong
points and weak points i think the
strong point was it shot really well the
acting's really good the story's pretty
good
the weak point is i didn't really like
the master vampire that much
it was kind of like a mr barlow
kind of thing from like kind of like a
nosferatu type nosferatu salem's lot
which i like that they were homaging
that kind of vampire because you don't
see as many of those in the vampire and
but voice i didn't like the voice of the
vampire you know who that was playing
what uh playing the master yeah it's the
same woman that plays uh veloc the nun
from the conjuring
movies you know what i mean that creepy
nun yeah yeah yeah
i guess they were trying to go for uh
like a [ __ ] carmilla lesbian vampire
type thing where it's like it's like
that but it's a it's a nosferatu looking
but that's that's cool i thought that
was a good idea
but the voice isn't sinister enough for
it
i liked how it looked even though i
think that was yeah i can't remember
that actress's name bonnie something but
yeah she's uh she's best him for like
playing vlog in the i wouldn't i would
have rigged that voice up to be
more intimidating like something like a
hissing sound or something
yeah yeah i mean it sounded too much
like a mortal woman right and it had to
sound a little unearthly i think i think
it would have been a little more i think
that's why
in salem's lot
they never had um mr barlow mr barlow
actually say anything because it might
have dispelled the way that thing looked
because that was a [ __ ] creepy
looking vampire real skinny see and
that's how you said because you you know
in the book salem's lot uh mr barlow
talks
and you thought that he should talk in
the movie i don't think he should have
talked in the movie so i'm glad that
they made the decision let's not make
him talk he's scarier when he's when he
doesn't talk he doesn't need to talk
he's got like his human well sidekick
that was the 70s
yeah and i think the reason why he
didn't talk is because it would have
been hard to make an intimidating voice
for that with the technology they had
back in the 70s
i generally think characters that don't
talk are scarier than ones that do talk
in general not always
because you can well because you can
project your own motives and stuff onto
them like like i said that's not a hard
and fast rule obviously but because
there are some out there like darth
vader
well yeah and like i said there's
exceptions right and darth vader's
original voice was [ __ ] proud and it
didn't sound good they had to [ __ ]
fold in
you know uh jones in there and uh
[ __ ] um
this
and then uh of course the whole
breathing apparatus and then the the way
that the the voice was kind of modulated
through
i guess tubes like a big speaking and it
[ __ ] sounded really good
with technology today you can make a
[ __ ] real intimidating vampire voice
that is female
um
and get it done right and the thing is
is that you don't give that character a
whole lot of dialogue
like you know i mean i think barlow
should have spoke
in salem's lot
but maybe not a whole lot of dialogue
but the voice had to be effective and i
don't think they could do the voice that
well for in the back in the 70s yeah
that's why they didn't do it but it was
in the book yeah
you know it would have to be a a darth
vader level
sound effect
you know yeah and i think it was a
little too much for a made for tv movie
but they could have done it here i think
although i mean the master isn't in it
all that much and like i said i like
when they kind of showed her at first
like she was just like in the shadows
like with the glowing eyes they didn't
really show her until the end
um i didn't mind the look of it like i
said i like that they were homaging more
like the nosferatu uh you know salem's
lot type of vampire rather than like a
sexy vampire
so i like they're going more in that
direction i have like seen a couple this
seems to have gotten like pretty
mixed to positive reviews i think one
issue that a lot of people had um some
people had an issue it's like you know
they thought the vampire's a little bit
goofy um which i wouldn't go that far
but i don't think it was goofy but yeah
i can get it and a lot of people thought
the tone of it was kind of strange
although that didn't really bother me
now this is travis stevens the guy that
wrote and directed this or co-wrote and
directed it was the same guy that did a
girl on the third floor and you remember
we did a we did a matinee on that a
while back um that was the one that had
cm punk and he got that house and like
that have had like weird like
you know uh what do you call them like
um what do you call those things that
are inside your body organs
it's like oregon spot
i'm getting old you guys organs like
behind the uh walls and stuff and that
movie had the same kind of thing where
it just has like this strange tonal
because this is almost
i don't want to say it's almost a
serious movie because it's not but it's
not outright a comedy either
and so i think that some people might
think the tone of it is a little weird i
didn't find that
but i can see how people would so
basically what the story is barbara
crampton
who like i said she was actually like a
producer on this she's been trying to
get this movie made for a really long
time because essentially like i think
what happened was a couple years back
she got this uh screenplay and she
really really liked it so she's been
kind of like shopping around like
helping to get it made you know what i
mean because she really wanted to be in
this
so she plays um you know jacob's wife
ann
she is this um
preacher's wife he's a minister i guess
uh played by larry fessenden who is also
[ __ ] great now the two of these uh
barbara crampton and larry fessenden
were also in a
horror movie a few years back called
we're still here which is also decent
although i think i liked this one better
we are still here had some problems uh
some issues with it
that you know i couldn't fully get on
board with it but
um i think i like this one a little bit
better
so uh larry fassenden plays jacob feder
and he is like this minister in this
small town they shot this in mississippi
i think yeah right outside jackson yeah
and um so so he's this kind he's not
like a bad dude he's just kind of like
you know him and his wife they've been
married a long time um he's kind of one
of those
you know
wife should be submissive to the husband
type of dudes but not like in an overtly
like real obnoxious he's not a bad guy
like i said he's just kind of like
clueless and he's just kind of into the
church
yeah and he's just not real concerned
about her feelings but not in a way that
he's that is like malicious it's just
that he doesn't really it doesn't really
occur to him type thing
so she's kind of like um i guess there
was a point because they kind of go into
it a little bit in the movie there was a
point where she was kind of like not i
don't know if she was like a wild child
or anything like that but she had like
big ambitions she wanted to travel and
live in cairo and all this other kind of
stuff and then she ended up like there
was a tragedy like her mom died or
something and then
she ended up marrying the preacher or
the minister and they've been married
all this time and she so she's just kind
of like this quietly like dissatisfied
kind of housewife type character
so what ends up so they kind of
established that at the beginning so
it's almost kind of like you know it's
not completely serious but it's almost
kind of like a serious relationship
drama like a little bit like for the
first like 10 15 minutes of it
and then it comes to pass that an old
high school boyfriend of hers whose name
is uh tom low i think his name is and
he's coming back into town because
they're gonna like refurbish this big
mill or something and um so he's come
back into town to like to kind of look
at it and see what they're gonna do with
it and so they meet up with one another
and you know start
sparks start flying and whatnot she
doesn't like [ __ ] him or anything like
that but she is kind of like and he's
kind of like you know what happened to
you i can't believe that you've been
married to a minister for 30 years and i
never would have thought that that would
have happened and you know blah blah so
there's that that whole kind of aspect
to it now while they're in the mill
they find these old like uh crates and
stuff and there's like a bunch of rats
and everything which like i said very
very salem's lot which very very dracula
also but salem's a lot it's kind of like
an updating of dracula i guess so um so
then tom law
uh gets i guess bit by the vampire and
then she gets bit by the master vampire
and because i should say too that
there's like a little bit of the front
where uh there's like a girl in town who
they're talking to at the church at the
beginning she's going home and she gets
attacked by the master vampire also
but so then uh so barbara crampton's
character anne uh essentially becomes a
vampire and she's uh kind of into it
you know what i mean
because it's kind of a it's kind of a
question of well you know she's been
married to this minister for all this
time and she's kind of kind of had a
boring uh unfulfilling life and now all
of a sudden she can carry furniture
around and she's like all foxy she like
feels like better than she's like you
know she's like gets to be all sexy and
stuff so it's like really interesting
like and then it kind of gets funnier
and funnier like not zany funny but like
kind of
funnier as she's sort of exploring this
new aspect of her and how her and her
husband like deal with the situation of
her now being a vampire you know what i
mean so it's like that's kind of where
where the movie's at yeah it's pretty
good
that aspect of it was pretty good i
think i think they should have stayed
more in that realm
um
but you know i don't know it's a lower
budget movie they did they did well with
what they had um the act is good you
know
i think i think really the only the only
thing that disappointed me was the was
the vampire's voice that was it
i could i would have had a a much better
voice and that was really only one scene
i mean she really only talked about it
and i was like oh well yeah that voice
it doesn't really
not really scary
here's another good example
of a mr barlow nosferatu style vapor
klaus kinski did a version which is
extremely eerie
real eerie because he was just so
awkward yeah
yeah he just made your skin so
and he just like he had some kind of
weird disease and he was yeah
[Laughter]
and she didn't
have that quality
it was just like a woman
yeah i don't i haven't seen all the the
conjuring movies or at least um all the
ones with the none in them but she
doesn't talk does veloc does she talk
i don't even know i think i've only seen
the nun
and then i can't even remember which
conjuring movie it was that first had
the nun in it was it conjuring two i
don't even know
i might be able to put it on the
director who didn't direct her very well
or you could have done that what she did
do and maybe use some kind of special
effects or some kind of voice over
you know
she her she moved well good she looked
good the little outfit that she had was
kind of like nosferatu's outfit from the
original movie yeah with the high
shoulder pads and button down the front
you know the costume looks pretty good
and it wasn't clear if she was a a woman
or not it or if she was well she wasn't
a woman she was a vampire whether
whether the vampire was female or not
wasn't really clear
you know yeah you couldn't really tell
from the movie because like i said she
looked like mr parliament she was like
bald and then they looked like and and
they went very yeah they went very much
with the rat like where it was just like
two fangs in the front because even like
barbara crampton has that at some point
too yeah
so so i like that they kind of went more
old school with it but like i said it's
almost kind of like like i said i kind
of feel like as some reviewers like a
lot of reviewers like i said it's gave
it like you know it's you know a decent
movie um but some people were like well
i didn't really like like the tonal
shift to me the tonal shift didn't seem
all that egregious i mean
it had humor in it uh it had a lot of
gore uh there's one particular scene
that i'm thinking of that was like
actually it was really really gory but i
actually i actually like really enjoyed
that um i think some people didn't like
the
you know oh it's a serious relationship
drama oh it's but i don't want to go too
much into saying serious relationship
drama because it's not that's
overselling it it's not a serious
relationship drama oh and by the way
there's vampires and then it's funny
it's to me it seemed a lot more
integrated but maybe maybe other people
didn't see it that way my good friend
connor watson says if anyone wants to
see a good dark strawberry series watch
the strain yeah i remember when we when
we reviewed blood vessel uh a bunch of
people like recommended that uh to us as
well so yeah we'll get around to that
because well i think uh guillermo del
toro was involved in that like to see
blood vessel again yeah that was a that
was a yeah because that's that's another
one that had like
old school vampires like i said i like
that we're kind of going back in the
direction of like making them like old
yucky ugly rat like monsters again
instead of like foxy's people who don't
know what a straggler is a stragoi was
the original vampire all right
yeah uh
[ __ ] what's his name um
a dude who wrote [ __ ] dracula uh
yeah brown stoker he kind of invented
the vampire in a certain way based upon
stories of stragoi and esther is not
really a vampire it's it was
kind of like the prototype
yeah it drinks blood
yeah it can it can it's kind of like the
undead but it's also a a sorcerer
uh has a bunch of powers involved with
like black magic
but it can cross breed with both the
dead and the living that's a weird thing
it can impregnate the dead
and then [ __ ] from that a child comes
out
that is half
dead
or or a living dead and then it can also
impregnate a living person and then that
person is born a living vampire
that when it dies it then becomes a
vampire but while it's alive it [ __ ]
has certain abilities it's a lot more
complicated this the stragoi was a lot
more complicated
and it its life cycle was a lot more
interesting i i think than a vampire
but they're they're kind of described as
rat like like a rat or a bat or a or a
and like when they do things like
impregnate a dead body what's born out
of that is more like a a little more
like a zombie
that's weird some weird weird [ __ ] which
like i said they did go into that in
blood vessels and you don't yeah and you
don't see enough of that in movies i
feel like right you know what i mean
yeah the strago is a lot more
interesting than a vampire if you ask me
well particularly i kind of feel like
well because you know all the rules of
vampires have been established for so
long which like i said bram stoker did
help lay that down but i feel like in a
you know for a time they were kind of
like narrowed down because particularly
after like anne rice's books came out in
the 70s then you had you know we had a
few decades of vampires have to be like
these sexy
uh you know old arrest aristocrats
that's why they were selected though and
stuff yeah you they were selected to be
made into vampires because they were hot
yeah you didn't want to make an ugly
person
and you didn't want to make an old
person into a vampire or a child and
that was part of the rules
well yeah because how [ __ ] up would
that be well like i said they did i mean
anne rice did explore that with the
character claudia why would you turn an
old people person into a vampire yeah
it's like gee thanks now i have
arthritis my whole life thanks a lot bud
right
and why would you make an ugly person a
vampire because then now they're
they're eternal basically but they're
gonna be
have the limitations of an ugly person
so there's a and that's
directly spelled out
in other words vampires were
supremacists
everything was about being superior
uh or you just couldn't be a vampire
um they selected superior people to
become vampires
but a struggle what i thought was
interesting about esther
different than a [ __ ] vampire is they
had abilities kind of like a vampire a
lot of it had to do with having sex with
living people or dead people depending
on whatever they wanted or another
vampire they could have sex with another
stragoi
they have mental abilities like
maybe a psychic might have but then at
the drop of a hat [ __ ] will pull out
some [ __ ] bones and some dice and
some tarot cards and start [ __ ]
working a magic spell
which that's kind of a [ __ ] cool they
were they were they were witches too it
was they were witches and warlocks
they had they had all the powers we're
all the monsters in one oh by the way i
can also turn into a wolf
and then oh by the way hold on to clear
the table off and you start doing things
and start doing doing sympathetic magic
and [ __ ]
and it works yeah
that's weird and it looks like a rat it
doesn't look like a person it's a
bipedal rat or a butt and they're big
testosterone infused [ __ ]
[ __ ] and his head looks like a
rat or a bat
well the original dracula in bram
stoker's novel was rat like i mean he
still looked like a person but he had
like rat characteristics yeah like to
his he had pointy ears yeah and he was
like kind of gross-looking yeah and then
blood vessel his his wife was a [ __ ]
hot rat
remember that a hot rat star boy it's
just kind of [ __ ] kind of interesting
but then he would have then they would
like
say [ __ ] it i'm gonna take a a a human
female as a wife they could do whatever
they wanted
and then that human female might be a
dead human female that's another kinky
ass aspect
just a corpse
yeah yeah
now it's not clear does it do they
reanimate it and then impregnate it
or do they just impregnate it when it's
dead a dead corpse and a child comes out
i don't know are we thinking about it
too much probably too much yeah because
it just seems like if you don't need to
reanimate the dead person then you could
just like [ __ ] well you could just shoot
your load into like something that was
like an artificial womb instead of
having yeah well
i just read about it they didn't show it
so i'm assuming that it's just a corpse
that you shoot your load into it and
what comes out as a child it's like a
zombie
yeah that's way red
but maybe they turned the woman into a
zombie and then that's his wife yeah
maybe that's what it is danny rowland
ghostface and i had actually forgotten
about this stephen king's vampire film
the night flyer uh has a vampire that's
a hideous [ __ ] chud as well but also
a pilot which is how he gets around
definitely a different take on the
vampire yeah i had totally forgotten
about the nightflyer now i have to like
see that again
uh just bees for now says makes make a
small penis vampire yeah yeah
yeah they're making a new candyman movie
they made a new candyman movie it's
starting uh friday actually it's gonna
be in theaters because i think next
saturday we're gonna go see it
camp guy said off topic but there is a
great new dennis nielsen documentary on
netflix has actual audio recordings he
made in prison yeah we actually watched
that i was going to do a matinee on it
but then we uh then we watched this and
i said well i guess i'll do this instead
but we can do that at some other point
although i was kind of thinking because
this is a vampire movie and then we also
have to do vampires with the y like the
lesbian one we have to do a matinee on
that so i said why don't we do like a
whole vampire week uh and then we'll do
like near dark or something like that
like on tuesday because i'm also on
thursday i'm putting up a review of only
lovers left alive which is also a
vampire movie so i was just like well
[ __ ] man we might as well just have a
whole vampire palooza this week you know
we don't have to but we just could
yeah and then uh
he also says tom savini aka sex machine
morphed into a rat like vampire and from
dusk till dawn yeah that's right that's
that was his name in that movie sex
machine tom savini yeah didn't you see
that from duskville dawn uh
yeah yeah yeah i didn't like it
i haven't seen it in a long time i
didn't like it i haven't seen it in a
long time
yeah louis says yeah vampires with the y
that's yeah we're gonna probably do that
one tomorrow because i don't watch that
one tonight because that one it was
actually because remember i said last
time when we had the movie retrospective
poll and it was a three-way tie
so we did witchfinder general we did uh
whatever the other one was um i think it
was graveyard shift and uh vampires was
the other one and we just didn't have
time to do it last week so we'll
probably do it this week but yeah so
this is like i said this they just got
this one on shutter
and
i really i don't know i really liked it
you know what i'm saying it's like it's
not the best movie in the world but you
know what i mean it's just kind of like
i i had a lot of fun with it it's
interesting because another criticism
that i saw was that a lot of the people
who get killed because a lot of people
get killed in this um
weren't really like important like it
seemed like she was just like killing
people like neighbors and stuff and like
nothing really got done about it because
she was a vampire you know what i mean
it was just kind of like oh okay well
that's supposed to um but i heard that
the blu-ray of this
had a bunch of um deleted scenes and in
the deleted scenes they went more a lot
a lot more into the characters that got
killed so you had like more of an
attachment to them because it's like in
one thing that i saw more than one
reviewer bring this up it's like a lot
of people die in this but it doesn't
really like you don't know who they are
exactly it's just or there's just like
one scene with them so it's like you
don't really care if they get killed but
like i said to me it didn't seem like
that wasn't really the focus i mean the
focus of the movie was her becoming a
vampire and dealing with like hey this
is like kind of awesome and then her
husband like trying to come to terms
with
her changing so it's almost kind of like
i don't want to go off and say oh this
is a big like metaphorical thing
uh you know but
it was kind of like that it was just
kind of like these people and they've
been married a really long time and then
suddenly she's just like blossoms into
this like different whole different
thing and he has to come to terms with
uh what she's like now and like dealing
with how he's treated her in the past
and blah blah so it's like there's some
of that too but it's not like super
heavy you know what i'm saying it's
still fun it's still gory um and
what and barbara crampton i'll watch her
in anything pretty much i'll pretty much
watch larry fessen didn't anything to
you because he's awesome she's good
looking in this man
yeah and those and honestly like every
single review of this i saw like
somebody had to point out at the bottom
it's like barbara crampton is still hot
as [ __ ]
60 something she still looks great yeah
she really does yeah she's still
attractive yeah
which uh that's rare in in in or that
was rare in women
um i think up until recently modern
technology said to have hormone therapy
and plastic surgery plastic surgery too
that helps too yeah
yeah dj maniac says i just watched near
dark today i really need to re-watch it
and i've been wanted to like do a
matinee so we'll do a matinee on a
probably tuesday um you better hurry
because shutter is dropping it at the
end of the month okay well [ __ ] it
hasn't been on there that long they just
added it at the beginning of august that
sucks okay well we'll watch it like
monday night maybe and we'll do a review
of it tuesday so because that'll still
be with the fox today august 22nd yeah
so uh that'll be good all right so
i'm gonna go like half an hour um yeah
but yeah this is on shutter uh it's good
check it out especially if you like
barbara crampton um this is a little bit
short but i i have to do
i have to record a
panel show
in a little while so i have to kind of
get ready to do that
uh so we'll be back tomorrow like i said
we'll probably be talking about vampires
uh vampires with the y the movie from
the 70s the lesbian one uh so yeah we'll
probably talk about that tomorrow
and uh so have a good rest of your
weekend you guys and we'll see you
tomorrow afternoon bye